well do you remember how you learned to
drive well I was trying to think about
that and I think I was where were you
living Florida on the Mickey Mouse Club
that's right that's right yeah I was
with all those kids so um I think I
would just drive around there like you
know back woods like areas to set oh
this is adorable wow wowzies oh my God
oh my word back Thursday pretending I
can sing with the camera whatever
you think that's fake when you say all
the kids were you there when because I
remember whenever I came up I found out
it was like Justin Christina Brittany
they were all right they were all in
that club together I was poor I'm gonna
be honest with you I only had the basic
channels I didn't have Disney Channel
either okay I never saw it yeah so I
never I was too poor but like were y'all
all in the same crew yeah so they were
the the like the really a lot of
massively talented people all in one
place they were all very talented like
the Christina and Brittany and Ryan
Gosling and Justin all those kids were
12 when I was 17. so I was a little
older I could drive I was cool yeah um
and then but they were wildly talented
yeah and um you know two of my best
girlfriends Lindsay and Alana were on
the show with me too and that's so cool
they're more my age yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm going home
[Music]